hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on fauna again today is
going to be the second video of today
the first video i covered everything
about your meander hold up [ __ ]
whatever you want to call the character
we also covered the breach map we
covered hold his armor her weapons her
gameplay so if you do want to see that
click the eye on the top right right now
and you'll be taken to that video
or you can after this video is finished
it'll be in the end card so you can go
right to that video and segue into that
totally i recommend that but today we're
going to be focusing on the balance
changes for the reworks of season 11 as
well as the new weapons as well which
look pretty cool so as always like to be
if you do enjoy guys subscribe if you're
new
i cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch ups and the
leaks if you guys want to be kept up to
date with everything happening within
the world of honor and never miss out on
an update definitely stay subscribed to
the channel
and with that let's get started but
first up is a little bit of a curveball
we got some spectator mode stuff to talk
about
spectator mode is obviously coming to
forum we just don't know when
it's been super long overdue to have and
it can really help custom matches with
your friends and even the competitive
matches retain their value within the
community
and that's the reason why this was made
was because of the competitive scene
on top of that it also allows you to
spectate your friends as well so if your
buddy's in a breach game and you're
waiting for him to finish so you guys
can queue up together like a dominion
you could spectate him without even
being in his game which is super crazy
and of course it supports people like me
content creators as well so we can make
really cool looking montages videos and
stuff like that
you get three different cameras free cam
player cam and tactical view tactical
views that top down mode when you die
well this will be available for all maps
all game modes and all platforms and you
can spectate whenever you want and you
can join whenever you want you don't
have to be in the very beginning of the
match for the person to queue it up you
can be right at the very end when
they're breaking and still
end up joining the match that's super
cool and there's an unlimited amount of
spectators it does nothing to do with
the lag of the game
it won't hinder your gameplay experience
so you can have as many people as you
want
for multiple camera views they're
originally going to be giving spectator
mode to a small amount of people in the
very beginning at the start of this
season and then to everyone at the very
end of year three hopefully this will be
me and i'll be one of those people but
we'll have to see in the future
and as well here's a picture on screen
of all the tournaments
that are going to be showcasing this
type of spectator mode
i highly recommend joining four honor
arenas or at least watching as he's a
good friend of mine i love for honorary
shout out him
he's going to be hosting his own 4v4
dominion tournament with spectator mode
and you can sign up and win all this
potential steal
the prize pool for every one of these
tournaments is going to be 1.5 million
steel
so go join all the infos on your screen
right now it's going to be all platforms
xbox playstation and pc
as well as the two regions eu and na so
everyone can join and at least one of
these one of you can join it so
definitely go get that steal and get
that money
so definitely go get that steal
for in terms of balance changes right
now we have a little bit of small things
that have to do with every hero then we
have a lot of specific things but we'll
get into the general stuff first
so first up i will i just want to
mention that everything i'm going to be
saying from this point on will be in the
description down below if you do want to
read through it there is
so many changes coming to this update
for the newest season that's going to be
launching on august 1st
so i highly recommend you click on the
link and either watch it with me
or click on it right now and watch it
after i'm done whatever you choose to do
i highly recommend that you look at the
link but for the changes for some
regular improvements we have changes to
escape
opponents can no longer roll away from
many of the mix-ups without being
vulnerable to faint in a guard break
unlocking to escape combat is a bit
slower and more dangerous than before
and opponents can no longer back strafe
away faster than they could stray
forward so this is more of just that out
of lock stuff which we'll be getting
into
even more of that later but it's more of
the rolling away from most of the moves
which was always a huge scapegoat
but now it's not going to be the same
anymore because it wants to keep players
locked into the fight
and not running away just to negate
damage all rolls are now vulnerable to
guard break from
zero to 333 milliseconds it used to just
be 300 now it's just an additional 33
milliseconds
same thing for now dodge is now
vulnerable to guard break from
the 633 milliseconds from zero so it
used to be
so it used to be just 600 now it is 633
branching from dodge to roll can now
only be performed between 300 and 400
milliseconds so it's a little bit of a
tighter window it used to be 300 and 500
guard breaking immediately after a faint
is now 300 milliseconds it used to be
400 so a little bit faster
and guardbreak countering or gb counter
has now a 300 millisecond window
used to be 200 so the window to gb and
opponent now
so the window to counter guardbreak and
opponent that is gbdu
is a little bit faster about 100
milliseconds faster the actual
guardbreak counter will begin 200 to 300
milliseconds depending on when you input
the guard break counter
this means if you input it immediately
as you used to it will come out at the
same time
but you have a little bit more of a
grace period now to input it
also when unlocking the branching to out
of lock roll or sprint it now requires
300 milliseconds it used to be 100 so
going from auto block roll or sprint and
stuff like that when unlocking will be a
little bit slower
also when unlocking the movement has
been cut to two meters it used to be
four during the unlock animation so you
won't be going as far
and now this is all for entering lock
mode when locked engaged
lock requires 300 milliseconds it used
to be different per hero could be 200
could be 400 it's not just a flat 300
milliseconds
you no longer have that defensive
property some heroes had it between 100
milliseconds and 300 milliseconds so now
nobody has a defensive property
when they enter it you can now also
change the stance at 200 milliseconds it
allows you to be in the stance when
entering the lock state when that's
completed 300
so before you would hop in then you
could pick your side so now while you're
hopping in
you can go into the left side and guard
just in case if like somebody's rushing
at you and you're out of luck
you can just rush up to them block the
left while you're trying to get into the
lock state so that can help you
and also when you're coming out of lock
the movement is now zero
you must retain you you can retain some
velocity in this from the previous
movement state but it's
not too much the reason for this is
because a lot of people would
zoom in and then out of lock lock out of
lock back and forth and back and forth
and try to get away from you
that really isn't the case anymore and
that's super annoying so they wanted to
fix that
a lot of stuff was just said i do
apologize there was a lot of words being
said like i said click the link in the
description but boys we aren't even done
yet
the roll is now five meters away and
it's for all heroes it used to be
different but it is now exactly five
meters
and for activating revenge when you're
standing it takes 100 milliseconds this
is the same as before
but when you're on the floor it also now
takes 100 it used to take 300
milliseconds so it's now the same speed
but that isn't even the biggest part of
this patch note
we have a huge list of changes for a
bunch of characters you guys have maybe
have known about the reworks i talked
about in my past video
but there's a lot more things that you
don't know about we have we have balance
changes for characters such as
shinobi nobushi orochi peacekeeper
tiandi
valkyrie warden berserker kensei
lawbringer shugoki
zhangjun aramusha blackprior and hito
kiri
that's a whole list of characters that's
probably half the cast
right in that list just for this one
patch some guys are going to be getting
a lot more updates some of them only
getting one or two changes or a bug fix
but regardless
we need to talk about it so we're gonna
go right down the line that the way that
they explain this and i gotta preface
this right away
technically none of these were actually
reworks they were all just balance
changes
nobody got a rework this season just
that fuckload of characters got a bunch
of changes so it's either
we get a couple reworks and a lot of
changes to a few characters or a
a small amount of changes to a lot of
the cast and for this season they just
did
small amount of uh balance changes to a
large majority of the cast and i think
that's okay
a lot of people were still preaching
about centaurian getting a rework and i
totally agree maybe next season though
for those changes in specific these
might be pretty game changing so we'll
have to see in your opinion there
but for nobushi hidden stance cannot
counter gb anymore
dodge attacks now branch into another
dodge a lot later
lead can stack and faster lights is the
main stuff that she has
for shinobi his backflip zone attack
kick all that stuff hyper armor is now
gone
basically all of his hyper armor is
basically gone you can now interrupt
sickle rain like most moves like shamans
bite shugoki's hug lawbringer's
shove you know backflip i should say you
know all that stuff that is now going to
be interruptable
raiders you know even raiders charge and
stuff like that that is going to join
the ranks of all those moves
rope doesn't beat revenge activation and
slide does not prevent revenge
activation as well
and on top of that guard is now a
standard 1100 milliseconds which is the
standard assassin guard
rip gladiator because uh that that
wasn't that wasn't in the changes
if i'm gonna be honest with you jj his
sifu poise range was reduced he can
still dodge moves like hidden stance but
it's not as far back as he used to be
because they want some moves to be able
to still hit him so he's not completely
invulnerable
berserker lights very small change
lights after feints now do a 13 damage
for orochi his top light is now 466
milliseconds this is also the same for
the zone and the side light finishers so
top light side light finisher and zone
attack are now 466 milliseconds they
used to be 500
a very small slight change nothing crazy
wasn't a huge gap of 400 to 500 just a
small little bit of 33 millisecond
changes
and rips riptide strike and also chain
if you happen to miss it
for kensei his side opener and his
second light now do 500
milliseconds he has less damage on his
top lights and more damage on his side
lights and heavies and soft fainted
heavies now do more damage as well
for pk deep gouge and dagger cancel was
500 milliseconds it's now going to be
400
light openers are now 15 and they used
to be 14
and the raposting stab is now a bit
faster
valkyrie now had valkyrie sweep has
faster recovery on miss
the heavy damage is a lot higher and her
shield tackle range is smaller but less
recovery on miss as well which is really
nice
diandi his light and heavy finishers
have less recovery so if you happen to
hit them or miss them
you can go right into another move a
little bit faster and this is also the
same for warden but only for his heavy
attacks
for arimusha he now has a 0.75 meter
forward movement and his heavy finisher
feints this really wasn't the case
before
so even with his gucci sandals that
apparently give him rock steady he
really can't move as fast so now that
they're going to give him a little bit
more forward movement when he does heavy
finish or faints
and for black pryor and hito kyrie their
zone attack strike now has guard break
vulnerability in the first 100 seconds
so so there is a possibility to gb them
out of their zone attack you just have
to be super quick with it
once again huge huge summary of it if
you want to know specifics it'll be in
the description down below because there
was so much to cover
and also quick mention there was no
reworks it was just a lot of balance
changes
for a lot of characters other small
little details is that sanctuary is
going to be getting a map change it's a
hell of a lot smaller now
sanctuary arena maps still exist but
this is going to be the ranked mode
version it's way smaller than the
original very bare bones in super small
and only available in ranked and custom
matches the devs are also testing a
feature called testing grounds players
can now have the opportunity to test
changes before they release before you
before you needed to download the test
servers a lot and it was really only on
pc and it was this big hassle
but now it's available in game to
everyone in the live game for all
platforms
so it's the old test server stuff we had
years ago but it will now be in game
no download required progress is shared
so no worries there
it will be in your statute area and the
faction map you can test it there
so if raider happens to get a new change
and you're a big fan of raider or want
to see if he's still overpowered or not
whatever
your case may be you cannot go test it
in there before releasing and
especially give feedback to the
developers which is huge the one thing i
have to preface is that if you're going
to use this
please give feedback because there's no
you're basically providing
no reason to even doing this if you're
just going to test it and not give
feedback that's the whole point of this
so for the new weapons in season 11 like
i said we're going to get a whole new
batch of them
here are some of the weapons on screen
now for the current roster of the
characters so basically everybody with
yarming gander because he's going to get
his own type of weapons
they look super crazy but the only issue
is that i couldn't get them all as
pictures so i ended up just recording
them but they're still all here no
worries they just aren't in pictures
like i used to do in my videos for this
stuff
so if you do need to pause the video to
see your specific weapon go for it i'm
not gonna blame you
because these guys go pretty quick while
looking at them spending maybe five six
seconds on the weapon and barely any
time kind of going into detail
minus a few characters that they showed
a big fan of the viking weapons
definitely them as a faction are my most
favorite in terms of faction weapons the
samurai also got some really good ones
too
not really a big fan of gladiators i'm
probably gonna still keep the ones that
i have from season four and season five
but that's just me maybe you guys really
enjoy that weapon but like i said i'm
gonna have to disagree with you on that
overall not too bad weapons i mean it
was way better than i believed last
year's which really didn't get too many
crazy good weapons i'm a big fan of
season 11 so far
but i feel like the executions are
probably the most hyped thing coming
for this new season okay guys it's going
to be the end of the video hope you guys
did enjoy it like the video if you did
as always subscribe if you're new i'll
cover the informational side of 400 that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patriots and the leaks
if you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
honor and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribed to the
channel you can click my most too recent
video
my two most recent videos are going to
be popping up on screen if you guys want
to check that out those are going to be
the executions as well as the new
stuff for holder her weapons her armor
and everything that we covered in my
previous videos today
so if you want to see the new executions
want to see her new armor some gameplay
some weapons
definitely go check those out but guys
have a great yesterday thank you for
watching the video let me know your
thoughts on hold up and everything in
this reveal stream in the comments below
and take care guys i'll see you later
you